Pour Brut, je me suis rendue à Carpentras.
Là-bas, j'ai rencontré Christophe
ou plutôt Niglo le vrai.
Une droite, pas deux.
Niglo, c'est un influenceur gitan de 23 ans
qui fait le buzz
avec des vidéos
où il se moque des clichés
sur sa communauté :
les gens du voyage.
Franchement, j'en connais pas des influenceurs gitans.
Ils aiment pas trop
se montrer. Ils ont la latch.
En gros, chez nous, ça veut dire qu'ils ont honte, un peu,
tu vois ?
On va essayer de poser une droite, pas deux.
Moi, je m'en bats les couilles.
Complet.
Moi, j'ai envie d'apporter de la joie, de la bonne humeur.
Une, pas deux, les amis.
Dans tous les cas,
tu seras critiqué.
Donc, fais, toi, ce qu'il te plaît.
Là, tu en poses une.
Pas deux !
Niglo, il vient d'une famille qui baigne dans la musique
depuis des générations.
Son père, c'est le flamenco,
mais lui, c'est plutôt le rap.
Et avec son pote RDS,
ils m'ont donné rendez-vous
dans leur studio d'enregistrement :
un mobil-home aménagé à leur image.
Le studio, il est juste derrière.
Si vous voulez qu'on aille
voir, c'est parti.
Là, on a le gamos, là.
On a même un garage.
Ça, c'est la pièce préférée de tout le monde.
Là, ici, on passe des soirées...
- Des soirées, des semaines.
- C'est ici que...
les sons, ils partent.
Ah, ouais.
- Voilà.
Bah, tu sais quoi, le mieux, c'est qu'on va te faire écouter.
Là, on vient juste
de recevoir le mix du son, là,
qui doit sortir.
On l'a clippé.
Et voilà, on va te le faire écouter en direct.
Allez !
Tu vas voir.
Même moi, je l'ai pas écouté.
J'espère qu'il est
pas éclaté, le son.
T'sais quoi ? On va te
montrer direct.
En fait, là, par exemple, on prend une prod.
C'est une instru, tu vois.
Genre, il met l'instru. On essaie de la valider à deux.
Et après, une fois
qu'on a fait ça,
bam,
on commence à taffer l'écriture,
on fait un son sur quoi, et tout.
Et après, de là, on va
en cabine,
tu vois ?
On fait un yaourt.
Genre, un yaourt, ça veut dire : tu dis n'importe quoi.
C'est pour avoir une topline.
Après, une fois que t'as la topline et tout,
bah bam, tu commences
à écrire
et après, on pose dessus.
Bah, moi, t'sais quoi, j'ai même pas commencé par le rap.
En vrai, moi, depuis tout petit, j'étais bercé par le flamenco
parce que mon père, il
joue de la guitare.
Et franchement, c'est
vraiment un monstre.
Et de là, il m'a appris à jouer un peu de la guitare.
Sauf que moi,
la guitare, en vrai,
je te mens pas,
j'aimais bien
mais au bout d'un moment,
j’ai dit : c'est bon.
Ça, c'était l'ancienne génération, et tout,
même si, tu as vu,
j'écoute des sons,
j'aime bien de temps
en temps gratter,
j’ai dit : "Moi, faut que
je fasse autre chose."
Et du coup, moi, je me
suis servi de ça pour...
J’ai dit : "Vas-y !
Je vais essayer,
maintenant, de faire
ce qui marche bien, et ce que j'écoute", tu vois ?
Donc, voilà, je me suis mis dans le rap un peu ambiancé.
Voilà, Brut, tu me niques pas,
parce que là, là, arrêtez de m'emboucaner,
parce que là, c'est juste un yaourt, tu vois ?
Là, c'est au feeling, on n’a rien préparé.
On va envoyer ça.
Là, c'est des petites onomatopées.
Oh, vas-y, c'est bon, j'ai...
Là, j'ai...
Je vais pouvoir écrire !
J'ai fait un petit Danone,
là, je vais pouvoir écrire.
Ouais, franchement, il est méchant.
Il a une qualité de fou.
- Quand t'es dehors,
on dirait pas.
Je te jure ! Et pourtant, c'est un mobil-home.
Euh... le plus long, c'est pour mettre les sous de côté.
Le faire, ça va vite.
Quand t'as les sous, t'es déterminé, ça va vite !
Bah, en travaillant, hein.
Moi, je travaille dans la fibre optique.
Je suis technicien.
Je fais pas la ferraille, moi.
Bah, c'est des clichés !
- C'est des clichés, ça !
Bah, on mange du hérisson... Ça, c'est des clichés.
C'est pour ça que moi, d'ailleurs,
mon blaze, c'est Niglo.
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Parce que, bah, les Gitans,
ils sont, enfin, à l'époque,
ils mangeaient, en vrai, mes grands-parents, et tout,
ils mangeaient les hérissons.
Après, maintenant, on les laisse tranquilles, peuchère !
Parce qu'ils sont...
C'est plus pareil,
mais du coup, c'est pour ça, moi, en fait, petit,
j'avais une coupe, tu vois,
c'étaient des piques
et à l'école, toujours,
ils disaient :
"Ouais, ta coupe, on dirait un hérisson, et tout."
Du coup, mon surnom, c'est devenu, en gros, le hérisson.
Sauf que le hérisson,
en gitan, c'est Niglo.
Donc voilà : Niglo. Et le vrai
parce qu'après, il y en a beaucoup,
ils utilisent le blaze.
Du coup, j'ai mis le vrai.
Je l'ai souligné bien
comme il faut, voilà :
Niglo, le vrai. Il y en a qu'un, pas deux.
Pas deux.
Et là, on va passer au REC.
On REC.
Vas-y, mais je vais le refaire.
Posé...
avec Yagmur en pèlerinage.
Vas-y, je vais le faire
comme ça.
Vas-y, c’est bon. C’est bon.
J’ai. J’ai.
Posé avec Brut.
J’suis sous vodka-Red Bull.
Ça donne ça.
Moi, je valide, hein ?
Moi, je valide aussi.
Tu valides ou pas, Yagmur ?
Si tu valides pas,
on le supprime
et on recommence à zéro.
Vas-y, bon...
là, je pense qu’on va manger.
T’attrapes là et moi,
j’attrape là.
C’est bon, c’est bon, c’est bon.
Je sais pas, regarde. Il doit
y avoir des bouteilles d’eau.
Regarde s’il y a
une bouteille d’eau.
Voila, ça tu vois, ça ?
C’te grillade-là,
nous...
Bah moi, depuis
que je suis petit...
Même toi, ça doit être pareil.
Chaque fois, l’été,
dès qu’on se retrouve quand y a un peu de famille,
les cousins ou quoi,
bam, chaque fois,
c’est ça, tous les soirs.
Obligé.
Une grille : “Eh, viens manger ! Toi, viens manger !”
L’oncle, la tante, le cousin.
Même si on te connaît
pas, tu viens manger.
Tu viens manger.
Ouais, c’est ça.
L’ami d’un ami : t’es le bienvenu.
Et voilà, tu veux quoi de plus ?
Une guitare ?
Après, y a des choses simples de la vie, mais c’est... Tu vois ?
C’est bien.
- C’est quoi, justement,
votre mode de vie, en fait ?
Notre mode de vie ?
C’est la liberté, en vrai.
Tu fais ce que tu veux.
Voilà, regarde. Comme là.
Quelle heure il est ?
Il est 11h.
Il est 11h du soir,
on est en train
de préparer une grille.
Il est 11h du soir.
On vit sur le moment.
C’est ça.
Voila, c’est : maintenant, on a envie de faire ça, on fait ça.
Nous, on n’est pas
voyageurs, nous.
Non, c’est pas
des voyageurs, eux.
Non, ça je te dis, c’est mon demi-frère, en fait,
du côté de ma mère.
Et ça, c’est le copain
de mon petit frère qui est...
Chez nous, on dit un gadjo.
C’est pas...
Il est pas des gens du voyage.
Y en a plein comme ça,
en vrai, des...
Qui après, à force
de rester avec nous, bah
ils restent, ils restent et...
ils se marient avec
des filles de chez nous.
Ça devient...
Ils sont comme nous après.
Toi tu pourrais te marier
avec une voyageuse ?
Non.
Alors,
c’est pas le fait de pas me marier avec une voyageuse,
c’est la famille
derrière qui est...
C’est : après, tu as
400 personnes
derrière toi, ma couille.
Ben là, on peut commencer à aller manger, hein ?
Est-ce qu’elles sont...
Elles sont cuites ou pas ?
Qu’est-ce que t’en penses ?
- Elles sont bien cuites.
- C’est pas mal, hein ?
- Ouais.
Je sais pas, frérot.
On met aussi la table, hein, chez nous.
- J’avais un doute.
T’avais un doute ?
Bah maintenant, voilà.
Si tu savais pas,
maintenant, tu sais.
Vas-y, le sang, jette la caméra,
viens manger.
Faut que tu reprennes
des forces.
Prends des forces.
Prends des forces
que demain,
tu vas en avoir besoin.
Parce que là, tu manges pendant trois jours, hein ?
Même si son rêve, c’est de pouvoir vivre de la musique,
quand il est pas en train d’enregistrer des sons,
Niglo a un autre travail
le reste de la semaine,
il est chauffeur-livreur.
Alors là, moi,
par contre, pour me motiver,
je mets la musique à fond.
Toujours la musique.
Toujours, partout, quoi ?
Partout.
Obligé.
Allez, go.
Yo, Fredo !
Ça va ou quoi ?
Ça va, tranquillou, hein.
Ça va ou quoi le S ?
Tranquillou ?
J’en ai deux pour toi.
- Là, tu charges quoi, ici ?
Là, c’est des pièces agricoles.
Pour les machines, euh...
Après, eux, ils sauront
mieux te dire
parce que, en fait, moi,
la marchandise, je sais
ce que c’est, un peu,
mais c’est confidentiel,
un peu. Tu vois ?
Ouais, parce qu’en messageries,
il y a tellement
de vols et tout que...
Tu vois, les palettes,
elles sont filmées et tout,
tu sais pas ce que tu transportes.
Allez.
Je vais le garder.
Ça se trouve,
un jour, celui-là,
il vaudra de l’or.
Non mais là, tu vois, je la falsifie, la signature, attends.
Tous les jours, je leur
fais des dédicaces.
Ouais, ouais.
Ciao, ciao. Bon week-end !
Allez, à lundi.
Allez, au revoir.
Ouais, ça fait cinq ans.
C’était mon premier métier.
Enfin, mon premier métier après forain.
Parce qu’avant,
moi, je faisais...
j’étais forain et après,
quand je suis parti de chez moi, j’ai fait ça.
Tu vois, là, tous les jours, là.
Je fais de la muscu, pas besoin d’aller à la salle.
Et voilà, fini de charger.
Là, on peut partir.
- Tu aimes bien ce taf ?
Franchement, ouais.
Après...
Après, voilà, faut un taf.
C’est pas mon taf de rêve, mais c’est bien.
Franchement, je préfère ça que...
je sais pas moi, travailler enfermé ou quoi.
Mon salaire ?
C’est entre...
Ça dépend, ça varie, avec des fois les heures sup ou quoi,
c’est entre 1600 et 1700 €.
Un chauffeur-livreur.
Ouais, y en a assez.
Tant que j'ai à manger,
que je vis bien,
que j'ai un toit, voilà,
après, c'est le principal.
Je demande pas d'être
dans le luxe ou quoi.
De toute façon, tu le vois,
je suis simple.
C'est pas parce que je suis connu sur les réseaux
ou quoi que je me prends pour quelqu'un d'autre.
Quand je peux aider, donner la force aux jeunes, ou quoi,
je le fais de bon cœur.
Moi, j'étais forain de gonflables.
Je tenais le château gonflable.
Ça, ça me régalait.
Ça et la barbe à papa aussi.
Et après, par contre,
le truc qui me régalait
encore plus,
c'est après la fermeture.
Là, la machine à poing...
Et là, j'allais et là, je chauffais tout le monde.
Bam, je tapais !
Tout le...
C'est pour ça que mon nom, c'est devenu "une, pas deux",
après.
Parce qu'ils voyaient que j'étais comme ça,
moi, même quand j'avais
17 ans, et tout,
j'étais tout fin.
Genre, y avait des : "Go, go, tu tapes à la machine."
Ils disaient : "C'est pas possible que le minot,
là, il arrive à faire plus
que nous."
En fait, depuis qu'il est petit,
Niglo se déplace de fête foraine en fête foraine
et son père lui a transmis sa passion pour la boxe.
Ses entraînements
acharnés l'ont mené
jusqu'à être sélectionné en équipe de France.
Mais après plusieurs blessures,
il décide de faire une pause.
Moi, mon arrière-grand-père,
il était boxeur,
mon grand-père,
mon père, il était boxeur,
moi, j'étais boxeur,
ma sœur, elle était boxeuse,
mon petit frère,
il était boxeur.
Nous, c'est vraiment...
de toute la famille,
tu peux pas trouver plus combattant qu'ici, en fait.
- Est-ce que la boxe,
c’est un truc de Gitans ?
Ouais, la boxe, beaucoup !
Déjà, de base, c'est...
On va dire que les Gitans,
c'est un peuple,
ils sont... ils aiment la bagarre.
Donc, en fait, c'est le moyen de canaliser ça
dans le sport, tu vois ?
Parce que c'est un peuple
qui vraiment...
Ils aiment ça.
En vrai, heureusement
que j'ai la boxe,
parce que j'ai un caractère qui est vraiment impulsif.
Et franchement, avec la boxe, ça me canalise.
Tu vois ? J'évacue.
Ça fait qu'après, quand je sors de la salle, je suis pfff...
Je relativise un peu plus,
on va dire.
Tu vois ?
Genre, c'est comme
une thérapie.
Parce que je pense que si j'avais pas la boxe,
ça serait le carnage.
Là, avec ça,
je m'énerve moins, tu vois ?
Euh, bah, déjà...
déjà, les a priori des gens,
les gens qui
manquent de respect,
parce que le respect,
chez nous, c'est important.
Les gens qui te... Pfff, je sais pas, qui te dénigrent
alors qu'ils savent pas
par où t'es passé,
qui connaissent pas ton passé,
qui savent pas ce que t'as fait pour être là,
parce que, tu vois, tu le vois depuis que tu es avec moi,
c'est du travail,
que ce soient les réseaux,
la musique, la boxe :
on n’a rien sans rien, en fait.
Tout ce que tu fais,
c'est du travail.
Tu arrives pas de là, d'un coup, tu es là.
Ça existe pas, ça.
Et du coup, voilà,
les gens qui critiquent, et tout,
ça m'énerve.
Enfin, mais maintenant,
je relativise, tu vois,
parce que j'ai compris un peu.
Là, tu veux voir, ça, c'est un protège-dents collector.
Regarde : “Niglo le vrai, une droite, pas deux”.
Là-dedans, t'as : 1 pas 2.
Et en plus, le drapeau
gitan : bleu,
là, t'as la roue rouge et le vert.
Tu as vu, ça tue, hein ?
C'était avant le...
On est en 2022 ?
Le dernier combat,
c'était 2020,
quand il y a eu le Covid,
après, ils ont annulé.
Pendant un an,
on n’a plus combattu
et ça a repris
cette année.
Et cette année, comme
j'avais les vidéos, et tout,
j'ai pas fait de combats.
Genre là, tu vas te mettre là,
après, tu vas réavancer
pour faire un peu plus zoom.
Après, tu décales un peu vers... Tu vois ?
- Tu m’envoies pas
des coups dans la gueule !
Non, t’inquiète,
t’inquiète, t’inquiète.
Les goldens, c’est
que pour le sac.
Vas-y, commence à filmer.
Tu me dis c’est bon
pour toi aussi ?
Hola, Sancho, je vais vous montrer comment poser
un menu maxi golden
pour Brut.
Regarde bien le S dans la tess.
Les entraînements officiels ou les entraînements avant ?
Parce que déjà, dès mes premiers pas,
mon père, il commençait
déjà à m'entraîner.
Parce que lui,
il regardait des films
de Jean-Claude Van Damme.
Il voulait que je sois souple comme ça.
Donc, il m'écartait les jambes en descendant comme ça
pour que je fasse
le grand écart.
Du coup, depuis tout petit,
j'ai de la souplesse.
C'est ça !
Et après, c'est pour ça
qu'il a fait de moi
ce que je suis aujourd'hui.
Et elle est où
la cassette de boxe ?
Elle était préparée, hein.
Ah ouais, bah, le p'tit, il boxe.
Alors, là, tu vas voir Christophe boxeur.
Tiens, je te la tourne vers toi.
C'est bon, là ?
Voilà.
Ils faisaient un gala de boxe
pour les petits.
C'était un samedi
et ils avaient invité tous les clubs du coin à boxer.
C’est vous qui avez filmé ?
Moi, j'étais la caméraman.
T'as vu ! Et le petit qui est en face, là, il a douze ans !
Et déjà, il avait pas peur.
T'y crois pas quand ils sont petits,
on dirait qu'ils vont toujours rester comme ça.
Même, t'sais pas quoi, même maintenant,
en vrai, tu t'imagines pas qu'ils sont grands comme ça.
Là, ce que je regarde, on dirait que c'est hier que c'est arrivé.
C'est vrai.
C'est pas hier, non, on dirait ? C'est vrai, hein !
Là, t'as le chien Tyson.
Même le chien, il a
un nom de boxeur !
Tyson ! Il est là-bas.
Regarde !
Même lui, il est entraîné. Regarde ! Boxe !
Même lui, il est entraîné. Oh là là, oh là, oh là, oh là !
Je vais lui faire de la compétition à lui aussi.
Je sais pas lire et
je sais pas écrire.
Et je voulais pas, moi,
que mes petits,
ils sachent pas lire,
pas écrire, ni rien,
qu'ils soient illettrés.
Donc, comme sa maman,
elle avait fait déjà
de l'école, et tout,
du coup, on...
J'ai été sévère sur l'école, moi.
Il fallait pas rater l'école,
faire les devoirs.
Ça les a menés à des diplômes tous les deux aussi.
Oui, ah oui.
Y a pas de souci.
Bah ici, là, c'est le terrain de mon grand-père,
que c'était un Gitan catalan,
et à ma grand-mère.
Et, c'est un terrain de famille.
Là, à côté, c'est mon cousin
qui habite là, ici.
Il y a une de mes tantes
qui habite là,
donc c'est comme un mobil-home.
Là, dans le cabanon qui est là,
c'est son fils
qui habite.
Voilà, c'est ça !
- Oui, c'est ça.
Tu vivrais après avec des étrangers, c'est pas pareil,
mais la famille...
On est un peu solidaires, nous, les gens du voyage ou
que ce soient même
les forains, hein.
Voilà, regarde bien, moi, je vis dans mon terrain.
Ici, il y a ma fille qui habite.
Voilà, ça, c'est son camping
et ça, c'est sa remorque-cuisine.
La remorque-cuisine, tu vois, c'est une caravane
toute équipée.
C'est juste pour faire à manger, tu vois,
t'as le lave-vaisselle, t'as, comment ça s'appelle,
le sèche-linge, le frigo, tout.
Ça fait qu’ils font
la cuisine dedans,
au moins, ça sent pas le manger dans la caravane.
Après, t’as des
gens, ils vont dire :
”Bah ouais, comment ils font pour vivre dans des petits...
des petits campings
comme ça ?”
Que t’as... Ils ont des
grosses maisons, tout ça.
Mais nous, ce qu’il y a,
on est toujours dehors.
Dans les campings,
on n’y vit pas, en vrai.
On y va pour dormir,
pour manger s’il fait froid ou...
ou s’il pleut.
Mais sinon, la plupart du temps, on est dehors.
En fin de compte, ça nous sert juste à se coucher, quoi.
Et à se doucher et voilà, hein.
Comme tout le monde.
Ah non, pas du tout.
Il va te dire, mon mari.
Alors moi... Ah, moi,
tu sais pas quoi ?
Tu l'enfermes !
Vivre en maison :
jamais de ma vie !
Je mourrai en camping.
Bah, il y a Niglo qui arrive.
Il sort de chez le coiffeur.
Ouais !
C'est la liberté,
c'est la liberté.
Parce qu'en vrai, là,
même qu‘on est
sédentarisés, et tout,
de temps en temps, tu veux... tu veux partir,
tu prends... t'attelles
ton camping, tu vois.
Tu vois, c'est pas comme
une maison.
Tu vas pas prendre ta maison, tu peux pas l'embarquer.
C'est cette liberté, et en plus,
comme je te dis,
t'es pas enfermé tout le temps, cloîtré entre les murs.
Et regarde :
là, on a les campings,
mais vu que les campings, c'est fait que pour dormir,
pour se laver,
et on mange dehors,
on reste dehors.
C'est bien, tu apprécies la vie.
Quand t'entends la nature,
t'entends les coqs
qui chantent,
les cigales...
Le message que j'ai envie de faire passer ?
Bah, c'est que nous, on est tous pareils.
Même que tu vis en caravane, que tu vis en maison
ou quoi que ce soit,
la nouvelle génération, je parle de nous,
eh bien, on est comme toute la jeunesse de maintenant.
On est pareils.
C'est pas parce qu'on a des coutumes, ou quoi,
que les gens, faut qu'ils nous voient arriérés
parce que, maintenant,
on a évolué.
Et on est encore peut-être plus dans le game,
moi, avec mes vidéos, et tout, que certains de...
de la jeunesse qui sont pas dedans, tu vois ?
Tous les ans, la communauté des gens du voyage
se retrouve aux Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer
pour un pèlerinage.
Ils y célèbrent la sainte Sara,
mais depuis deux ans, l'événement était annulé
à cause du Covid.
Et pour la première
fois cette année,
les Gitans de France et d'ailleurs se retrouvent
pour accompagner
leur sainte jusqu'à la mer.
Là, il est street, là.
Voilà, on est arrivés
au Saintes, là,
pour le pèlerinage.
Donc là, on est arrivés de bonne heure,
donc ça va,
on a pu se garer,
mais après, ça va
être la zone, hein.
Ah, c'est un message de paix.
Et en vrai, ça...
Comment te dire ?
Ça t'apporte du bon pour toute l'année, et tout, tu vois ?
C'est comme si ça te protégeait.
C'est comme ça, tu vois ça, par exemple,
ça, pratiquement tous les Gitans qui sont croyants l'ont.
Ça, en gros, c'est pour t'enlever le mauvais œil.
Et genre, ça te protège,
tu vois ?
Bah, un petit peu
quand même.
Comme il l'a dit, c'est pour... Tout le long de l'année,
ça porte pas bonheur, mais...
Après, soit tu y crois,
soit tu y crois pas.
C'est comme les musulmans, leur but,
c'est d'aller à La Mecque,
c'est ça ?
Nous, c'est pas notre but,
parce qu'on peut
y aller souvent,
c'est à côté.
Mais c'est bien d'y aller.
Vas-y, faut qu'on y aille maintenant.
On va faire un tour au centre-ville...
Parce qu'après, y aura
tout le monde.
Au marché, et tout.
Ça, tu vois, ça,
ces couleurs, là.
Ça, c'est le drapeau gitan.
Ça, ça représente le ciel.
Ça, c'est la terre, tout ce qui est la nature.
Et ça, c'est la roue
de la roulotte.
Et ça, c'est le drapeau gitan.
Des communautés
des gens du voyage,
des communautés roms, sintis, tout, tout, tout.
Ça, c'est... C'est celui-là,
le drapeau.
Voilà, exactement !
Tu as même les sabots,
et tout, là.
Une, pas deux !
Tu connais le S !
- Une photo ?
Allez, vas-y !
Merci, mon gros !
C'est bon ?
Impeccable.
Allez, vas-y !
Une droite, pas deux.
Une droite, pas deux,
tu connais.
C'est ça ! Bah, ouais, surtout les jeunes, tu vois ?
Les jeunes, comme ça, et tout,
c'est la nouvelle génération.
Celle-là, ils suivent, ils sont connectés sur les réseaux,
ils sont connectés
sur les réseaux.
Ah, du coup, c'est bien,
ça fait plaisir.
Une, pas deux !
- Ouais, tu connais.
Ah, faut mettre ça :
une, pas deux !
Une, pas deux !
Une droite, pas deux !
Tiens ! Tu nous prends
en photo ?
Vas-y.
Merci !
Impeccable !
- C'est un plaisir !
Non, franchement,
ça fait plaisir,
ce que tu fais pour nous tous.
C'est bien de montrer que, nous aussi,
on se sert aussi
des réseaux sociaux.
C'est ça !
Qu'on est là,
qu'on est présents.
Exactement.
Et qu'on n’est pas que ce que
certains veulent
montrer à la télé.
Ouais.
C'est exactement ça. Tu vois ce qu'il dit ?
Bah, voilà pourquoi je fais
des vidéos.
Ah, tu régales, merci beaucoup !
Reculez-vous !
Apparemment, tu vois, quand ils la portent à la mer,
quand tu touches Sara,
ça porte bonheur pour toute l'année.
Là, vraiment, j'ai la chair
de poule, là.
Tellement.
S'il vous plaît,
s'il vous plaît.
Laissez passer !
Bénissons le Seigneur.
Alléluia, alléluia.
Alléluia.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a intéressé
et si vous voulez voir
d'autres contenus,
c'est sur la chaîne
YouTube de Brut.
À bientôt !